corinne est ce que l'on appelle une
résistante son salon de coiffure est
devenu une institution à
quarré-les-tombes voilà maintenant vingt
ans qu'elle travaille dans ce petit
village du morvan et depuis les clients
sont toujours rendez vous l'activité est
plus calme du zoo en hiver et autrement
six mois de l'année avec les maisons
secondaires ça bouge énormément
les commerçants zones rurales car elle
est tombée fait figure d'exception
quatre restaurants une pharmacie une
supérette de boucher et même une station
service
tout ça pour seulement 700 habitants et
ce n'est pas simone et odette qui vont
s'en plaindre
les deux retraités ont leurs petites
habitudes on trouve tout un carillon
c'est quand même très important
ah ouais ce crime chance parce que tout
autour ya des petits ménages mais y'a
rien du tout alors quand on vieillit
c'est pas drôle
un des secrets de cette vitalité des
commerçants déterminés à sauver leur
village quand un commerce ferme
il faut rapidement le rouvrir c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait sébastien il
vient de racheter ce fonds de commerce
le bar avait fermé il ya à peu près au
mois de novembre
nous on a décidé de le racheter on
refait des travaux on a encore un peu
près trois semaines de travaux on
devrait pouvoir leur ouvrir au 15 avril
normalement avec ce nouvel établissement
sébastien possédera désormais deux
barres sur quarré les tombes de quoi
accueillir plus de clients le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que si tu as des
commerces qui ferment en fin de compte
le village commencent à mourir commence
toujours par les écoles ensuite le café
la boulangerie et à la fin il n'y a plus
rien un petit village aux portes du
morvan qui résiste encore et toujours à
la désertification les commerçants de
quarré-les-tombes n'attendent plus
qu'une seule chose le retour de l'été et
son cortège de touristes